et conques où tout le monde de quoi on
parle aujourd'hui eh bien on va parler
du mwc le mobile world congress qui est
tout ce qui se tient à barcelone alors
c'est une édition très spéciale c'est
l'édition j'avais pas poste comme il
peut associer patate est fini mais on
approche on croise les doigts de la fin
c'est mw c'est aussi un peu particulier
parce qu'il n'a pas encore tout le monde
ya toute une partie de l'asie qui est
pas venu une partie des us qui n'a pas
été présente mais néanmoins il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs il ya beaucoup de
stands alors je vous ai fait plein de
vidéos pour vous parler du mwc je vous
invite à voir toutes les vidéos sur ma
chaîne parce que les sujets qui sont
extrêmement passionnant on parle de
smartphones mais pas que aujourd'hui
j'ai choisi de vous faire un sujet un
peu à part c'est des produits des sujets
un peu transverses qui ne nécessitait
pas une vidéo dédiée mais je trouvais
vraiment extrêmement intéressant donc je
voulais absolument vous parlez donc
aujourd'hui on va se faire tout seul on
pourrait dire une espèce de best of du
mwc ou alors des sujets un peu what the
fuck ou de la grande aventure va y avoir
du voyage va y avoir du suspense par des
smartphones va y avoir du robot va y
avoir beaucoup de choses et on en parle
tout de suite et ça croyez moi c'est
vachement intéressant
[Musique]
ok super intéressant en arrière c'est un
robot barman alors on se dirait ok moi
j'ai pas envie d'aller voir dans un bar
où il ya un robot barman qui ne savait
ce que ça montrait ce qui est
intéressant c'est déjà d'une la
productivité parce qu'avec ses deux
mains il peut faire des mouvements
différents et peut venir vous chercher
une piña colada vous servir un verre
avec tact axa prend ça sert à ça va
extrêmement vite et puis surtout savoie
où peut aller la robotique dans la ville
du futur qu'est ce qui peut arriver en
tout cas on peut le voir dans les bars
on peut le voir dans les restaurants on
peut voir dans plein de choses ya un
côté certes déshumanisé mais en termes
de techno c'est vachement intéressant
puis surtout ça vous évitera de faire la
queue au comptoir lorsque vous serez
avec des potes et que vous voulez
commander di maria et rita ya un côté
intéressant pour la margarita on est
dans quel monde on est ici chez red
magic avec un nouveau smartphone c'est
le raid magic 7 alors ici ce qui est
vachement intéressant c'est que déjà
vous avez un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 165 m c'est ce qu'on
a de plus aujourd'hui sur le marché il a
plein de particularités vachement cool
et surtout regardez vous avez ici vous
voyez passer un petit ventilateur alors
deux ventilateurs j'ai un petit bouton
je viens l'activer là je vais à mon
ventilateur qui tourne donc là c'est
vraiment la partie refroidissement
active également du refroidissement
passif comme sur beaucoup de smartphones
alors je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
aujourd'hui mais surtout ça m'intéresse
que je viens éteindre mon ventilateur on
le voit qui s'arrête ici donc ça c'est
assez rigolo c'est vraiment lorsqu'on
est dans une partie de hardcore gaming
et puis après vous avez un petit bouton
dédié qui va lancer les mots de guémy
vous allez arriver effectivement sur
tous vos jeux on se trompe si je par
exemple et là vous avez l'heure des
petites rigueur la pousse avion vous
allez pouvoir dire moduler pour sauter
vous faire plein de choses bref on peut
bien paramétrer tout ça et là sur le
côté hop là vous venez sur ip là vous
avez énormément d'informations pour le
gaming vous pouvez venir régler votre
luminosité choisir votre taux de
rafraîchissement alors là on est sur du
165 m mais on peut venir le descendre si
on souhaite parce que convenir gagner un
petit peu aussi en autonomie on a tous
des championnats est actif de 360 m mais
on peut bien le monte carrément en 720
air sera effectivement on va consommer
davantage mais c'est à vous de voir si
vous voulez jouer énormément si vous
voulez que sa partie d'un axe que vous
avez également un mode de charge qui est
intéressant vous voulez le plugin
directement dans le secteur il viendra
pas recharger la batterie va juste venir
alimenter le smartphone idée c'est de
pas venir endommagé la batterie en lui
mettant décide alors qu'on joue comme un
dingue et qu'on a juste besoin d'avoir
la batterie donc je trouve vachement
intéressant je trouve assez joli dites
moi si ça vous intéresse vous voulez
qu'on vient de tester le raid magic 7
est vrai qu'on aille plus loin sur cette
polo j produit vous me dites parce que
on pourra se le faire ça vous intéresse
on peut en parler mais ça c'est à vous
de me dire et ça vous intéresse on le
force sinon le fera pas il ya une
innovation qui est très marrante chez
huawei c'est cette montre alors allez
pas du tout destiné aux marché français
en fait c'est une montre qui vous permet
de venir prendre votre tension
artérielle directement c'est pas des
capteurs de pression sanguine qui vous
permettront de déduire des choses dont
on parle vraiment d'une vraie prise de
tension avec un petit brassard à
l'intérieur qui va venir se gonfler pour
comprimer vos veines et prendre votre
tension et ça c'est plutôt rigolo vous
avez cette partie là la cavalière se
gonfler et rendez vous le voyez vous
appuyez rahil voyez blood pressures
c'est votre pression avec la cie stolic
la diastolique et vous avez votre
pulsations ici vous pouvez mesurer en
appuyant là donc ça c'est rigolo bon
c'est pas pour la france très
honnêtement d'ailleurs je sais même pas
si vous aviez besoin vous ne mesurez
votre pression artérielle est ce que
vous le feriez avec un projet comme
celui-là on glisse d'un monde connecté
une ovation que je trouve hyper
qu'annoncé ça c'est le wait station x
alors on pourrait dire ok c'est un
moniteur comment on a vu beaucoup qui
sont très bien chez huawei c'est pas un
moniteur en fait c'est un ordinateur
regardez vous venez vous passez par ici
et vous avez tous qui intègre et ici à
l'intérieur ici c'est un hindou ça
résonne c'est 5000 h vous avez vos pores
sur le côté est ce qu'il y en a ici des
ports c'est la question vous avez ici
deux usb cg 2 usb de l'autre côté j'ai
une prise jack on est dans un
environnement qui est extrêmement
lumineux et on voit extrêmement bien et
regarder ça vous fait un énorme laptop
pour venir bosser alors on connaît déjà
un peu ce format mais chez huawei ça
arrive t'on ça vachement bien stations
de travail le format est hyper qui
annonce je sais pas si c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait vous intéresser mais
moi j'aime bien cette idée de compacité
et de designers ça rappelle très
clairement des machines de apple mais le
boulot est bien fait là vous avez un
produit qui est tout nouveau alors on ne
sait pas s'il va sortir c'est pas une
liseuse c'est le met pas de people
l'idée est l'accord pris pour je vous
fais vraiment comme ça c'est qu'en fait
tu pouvais venir prendre des notes pour
venir travailler chez la voix qui
déraille tout va bien vous avez votre
agenda vous avez vos emails donc c'est
plus que les os n'est pas une liseuse
c'est un petit ordinateur dans cette
espèce d'idée donc lhi effectivement un
petit délai une petite latence tu peux
venir dessiner je peux bien griffonné
alors avec différents types d'écriture
j'ai vraiment une sensation de retenue
sur le sol doit avec le stylet quasi
rigolo g côté pum dangbo le pen ça c'est
mon petit stylo un peu standard je peux
choisir gré white et puis ensuite un
côté un peu plus graves envoyés et alors
ce qui est assez rigolo c'est que si je
prends le côté très fins voyage comme ça
mais si j'appuie fort bien ça me grossi
un peu trop l'idée très sympa maintenant
je me dis acquis pour qui quel marché je
ne pense pas que ce soit un produit qui
arrive en france mais en tout cas l'idée
est là ça ouvre des réflexions sur cette
typologie de produits est ce que vous
pourriez vous allez dessus est-ce que
c'est des choses qui pourraient vous
intéresser moi je trouve ça assez
marrant je ne pense pas qu'ils
aujourd'hui un vrai marché en france
pour ce produit là mais c'est à
réfléchir en tout cas ça vous dépasse
pectives huawei lancé ya pas longtemps
le paie 50 pocket alors sans un format
qu'on avait déjà vu notamment chez
samsung vous les présente également chez
tsl avec le chicago que j'ai vu à vegas
mais là c'est différent parce que vous
avez ccre en rond à l'avant qui est
complètement utilisable pour venir
naviguer votre caméra vous cliquez
dessus vous rentrez dessus vous
ressortez comme ça enfin il ya pas mal
de petites fonctionnalités assez
rigolote je trouve très canon ce petit
format et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que j'ai l'impression que huawei
cherche à féminiser sa gamme avec des
produits qui ressemblent un peu à des
bijoux on est dans une idée un peu du
bijou et je trouve ça c'est mort et je
vous le montrer sur un autre produit
parce que ça me fait vraiment penser à
ça c'est un form factor qu'on a déjà vu
avec samsung qui est hyper hyper canon
l'idée d'utiliser en écran qui se plie
pour venir réduire l'encombrement et
avec un produit qui est juste hyper a
été un million donc voilà je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez c'est un format qui
vous plaît ou pas moi j'aime bien alors
après attention ce que vous voyez là
c'est duos temps il ya un flic heures de
fou vous aurez pas ça si vous vous allez
sur ce produit soyez tranquille mais non
voilà j'aime bien je trouve je trouve
assez assez rigolo ça à votre avis c'est
quoi alors regardez l'ours est très
rigolo ce sont des freebug lipstick
c'est à dire que ça en fait des free
buzz pour imiter l'idée du rouge à
lèvres je trouve ça hyper hyper ma une
fois de plus c'est dans l'idée de la
féminisation de la gamme pour venir à
tirer une nouvelle c'est une nouvelle
clientèle font ça hyper vaut alors sur
les écouteurs sont des freebox on
connaît les free buzz de huawei ça
fonctionne bien mais là ils ont fait un
vrai travail au niveau du design pour
venir chercher une nouvelle cible est
sous sa très drôle donc je sais pas vous
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait vous
plaire si ça vous plaît si vous aimez si
vous n'avez pas d'ailleurs de dites moi
ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires parce que je trouve que
c'est extrêmement bien vu et puis c'est
vrai que latex arrête et on voit au
niveau des stars et personnalités
regarde la vidéo c'est très très
masculin donc l'idée de venir draguer
une nouvelle cible avec un design comme
celui là est assez marrant c'est très
membres et là on a un autre produit qui
est plutôt rigolo c'est le my book alors
le met debout que vous le voyez comme ça
vous vous dites ok 5 tablettes et en
fait c'est pas du tout une tablette vous
êtes ici sur un vrai windows fonctionnel
c'est un windows rose donc c'est un vrai
ordinateur et pour autant les gens ont
vraiment joué la carte de la mobilité un
ordinateur qu'on peut venir plié très
facilement on peut le prendre avec soi
on peut aller se balader il existe avec
juste la partie ordinateur comme ça vire
utilisé à la main ou avec un stylet
pourquoi pas ou de plus intéressant
c'est quand même le package complet avec
le clavier pour l'utiliser comme un
ordinateur emmener partout avec soi et
c'est intéressant dans le positionnement
de marque comme huawei en disant ok le
monde du pc on le connaît on vient
innover on vient proposer autre chose on
vient bousculer un peu les choses à je
suis pas convaincu que ce produit là on
retrouve partout à grande échelle parce
que ça reste quand même très riche et
mais ça répond à un problème qui est
très actuelle c'est à dire on a besoin
de puissance on a besoin d'un ordi mais
on veut quelque chose qu'on peut emmener
partout facilement avec nous et c'est
vrai que ce format là il est hyper canon
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez à ce que ces types de produits
que vous pourriez acheter pour emmener
pour la mobilité mark et moi tout ça
bien évidemment dans les commentaires et
si vous avez mise à jour du macbook x
pro est ce que je trouve marrant c'est
le boulot qu'ils ont fait au niveau du
trackpad regardez votre trackpad ulien
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
bout alors pour autant cette partie là
là tout au bout elle n'est pas tactile
mais juste là là c'est tactile vous
voulez naviguer je trouve ça rigolo
parce que je voulais déjà dit ouais ils
font très très beau boulot au niveau
matériel au niveau logiciel aussi mais
là au niveau matériel montre vraiment la
force de frappe manque la
différenciation et montrent qu'ils sont
capables de faire avec en tout cas à mon
sens un trackpad comme ça je n'ai jamais
vu et je pense est rigolo avec ce petit
travail qui est fait aussi au niveau de
l'encoche ça lui donne de la gueule et
je trouve ça chouette
[Musique]
ça c'est super drôle c'est sur le stand
de sherwood mwc regardez c'est le saiper
dogues lci bordeaux que c'est quoi et
bien c'est un petit robot alors
rassurez-vous la robotique animal ne va
pas arriver chez vous demain vous pouvez
pas venir adopter mais c'est super
intéressant de voir ce qu'ils sont
capables de proposer ici alors si vous
le voulez vous pouvez trouver 1500 euros
mais pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'
usage vous avez effectivement des
caméras et à pouvoir vous reconnaître
qu'à pouvoir vous suivez vous pouvez
courir et il tombera derrière vous mais
il n'y a pas réellement usage pourquoi
est ce que je suis on me l'a fait il ya
pour permettre aux développeurs de se
l'approprier pour venir créer des usages
alors il ya plein de porc dessus un peu
yard branché en usb et compagnie mais on
voit que le réel intérêt sur bois et
bien c'est lorsque les développeurs
auront frais des usages ça peut être un
animal de compagnie peut-être pour de la
défense j'en sais rien en tout cas on
voit que la robotique c'est un sujet qui
se développe qui intéresse des marques
comme schumi donc on regardera ça très
près on le suivra faisait parler de
robotique os et ios et voyez même ici on
a donc ça c'est vachement bien et ici
c'est un salon mobile ce n'est pas un
endroit boutique mais quand même ça
envoie du gros et là est ce qu'on n'a
pas un truc intéressant la télé
transparente de shiomi je vous parle à
travers une télé vous voyez le papillon
peut-être sur l'écran moi je le vois un
peu je devine derrière et vous vous êtes
de l'autre côté vous me voyez alors bien
évidemment cette télé ça va être
compliqué de l'année chez soi comme ça
parce qu'on voit à travers et c'est pas
forcément le but mais on voit la
technologie on voit l'innovation même si
elle n'est pas à vendre et bah c'est
quand même assez rigolo et ça fait son
petit effet
[Musique]
la jeanne faire une expérience qui est
absolument incroyable la boîte s'appelle
haptique ce sont des californiens ils
seront à san francisco est truqué dingue
pourquoi parce qu'en fait vous savez
lorsqu'on est dans un monde en réalité
virtuelle quand on veut toucher des
choses dès qu'on arrivait alors ses
mains pour nager pas m'avoir elle est là
on passe à travers les objets et c'est
nul ça c'est nul c'est bien mais c'est
très limitatif qu'est ce qui se passe
ici bien vous avez un casque de réalité
virtuelle on essaie un casque de htc
vaille vous avez des petits capteurs qui
permettent effectivement piraté un
système de sensors permettent de vous
repérer ce qui fait qu'on voit vos
mouvements au cap de vos mouvements dans
l'espace dans tout le système devait rc
ou est ce que vous êtes on voit vos
mains voilà ça c'est vachement bien donc
ça c'est la base ça vient pas de chez
eux qu est ce qu a fait à petit ils ont
créé un système avec des gants dans
lequel vous allez avoir des petits
capteurs ici fasse pas dans les capteurs
c'était pas des moteurs je peux vous
expliquer ça en fait c est propulsée
grâce à de l'air à haute pression et en
fait ça permet quoi vous l'avez vu un
sur mon dos gesat air comprimé et grâce
à l'air comprimé lorsque je vais toucher
des choses dans le monde virtuel et bien
ça vous envoie des petites impulsions
alors on sent pas des impulsions à air
comprimé mais on a l'impression de
ressentir les objets c'est vraiment
l'expérience que j'ai fait ici c'est à
dire lorsqu'on me dit touche quelque
chose je le touche mais en fait cela
s'arrête pas là c'est pas juste
retouchée par exemple si je suis en
train de prendre quelque chose et que je
force et bien je vais passer à travers
donc ça limiterait l'expérience ici on
va plus loin en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que j'ai des petits comme des
petits freins qui vont venir ralentir ma
main qui vont faire que car je veux
aller plus loin si je veux vraiment
prendre je peux saisir mais ça va me
bloquer donc j'ai vraiment plongés dans
un monde virtuel où je vois des objets
je peux les bougés par exemple jouent un
tiroir je bouge quelque chose j'actionne
un levier je le ressens et en fait ça
c'est intéressant pourquoi parce que ça
permet à mon cerveau de vraiment se
sentir immergé alors il ya eu un petit
moment de flottement je me suis dit bon
je me sens un peu moins bien il ya un
ascenseur qui a descendu il ya un côté
un peu nauséeux parce que bien que je le
vois je ne ressentais pas mais tout le
reste n'est ressentie et c'est
extrêmement bleus font alors c'est pas
parfait il ya certaines choses que je
n'ai pas senti avons envoyé des petites
gouttes qui tombaient je mettais ma main
je le sentais mais notre côté je me
sentais pas pourquoi parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'air comprimé qui venait
de l'autre côté donc c'est vraiment
intéressant pourquoi parce que même si
tout de suite on n'est pas prêts là
dessus et même si tout de suite on sait
que ça va appareiller pour le grand
public ça va commencer par l'industrie 1
où ils pourront venir travailler sur les
opérations de maintenance et plein de
choses mais son côté divertissement
grand public réalité virtuelle dans
l'idée de metaverse ça dessine des
choses ça commence à écrire une histoire
c'est le fait de se dire ok on s'immerge
des sympathiques mais là si on arrive à
aller plus loin en imaginant pourquoi
pas des combinaisons intégrales avec des
techno alors en face balader avec un
compresseur à air comprimé sur le dos
mais si on arrive à aller plus loin
miniaturisés des choses vont peut-être
trop des solutions alternatives eh bien
vous pour être vraiment dans un monde
virtuel totalement immergé avec des
sensations complet sur votre corps
pourquoi pas en tout cas c'est très
intéressant et là ce que j'ai vécu je
n'avais jamais vécu de la vierge en
effet pas mal ça un peu autre chose et
ça me plaît mais moi ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire et voilà ça y est
vous savez tout on a fait lyon a fait un
tour chez magnard complet mais presque
on a vu plein d'autres choses qui est
extrêmement intéressante mais il a fallu
faire des choix c'est une vidéo qui est
un peu longue mais je voulais partager
tellement de choses avec vous alors des
salons dorffer ou en faire des tonnes
dès qu'on pourra dès que ça va continuer
j'espère toi que la situation va
continuer à s'améliorer on croise les
doigts prochain au salon ça devrait être
l'ifa début septembre et puis il y aura
des événements y aura d'autres choses
des lancements des produits et
nouveautés donc tout ça le regarderai
ensemble ce que je vous invite à faire
ça va venir vous abonnez vous avez le
bouton rouge où était susi l'est où je
voudrais pas bonne et et d'ailleurs si
vous n'êtes pas abonné actionner la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié avec
une prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
vraiment génial d'ici là la fête quoi
vous prenez soin de vous voilà vous
allez voir votre famille vos amis les
gens que vous aimez et vous leur faites
décalage aimons les eaux qui fait mouche
je crains qu'à la all amont les eaux je
te faire un câlin vous fait des câlins
aux gens que vous aimez vous prenez soin
de vous et puis n'oubliez pas la vie est
courte il faut s'amuser vous embrasse à
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]